hey
i saw your post i'm here to help every
time you think you have cory figured out
you're wrong
here laura peterson has told her to
abandon her family that they're dragging
her down and here is corey in her moment
of need saying no no your family is all
that matters and i'm going to help you
find him i think it's going to create
for bradley a crisis and it's these
catastrophic events that really push
people together
i love you
cory is overwhelmed by the feeling of
love for her and he's heard that this is
what people say and so it just comes out
of his mouth it's authentic and it's so
what we've been craving since we watched
them in season one and we were like kiss
her kiss her i love the way that carrie
wrote it she's just a wild and talented
genius
daniel i really need you to come back
okay well that's very sweet and very
stupid
i'm very much appreciated but
i quit the morning show is really trying
to tell the story of what it's like to
be a woman of color in this level of
position and how mia is hoping to make a
difference and so she's very very
focused on dealing with daniel's changes
to his own goals can we just be friends
and
not talk about work
for once how are you holding up i love
how carrie did not make daniel and mia
one-dimensional i think me is probably
the person who is the hardest on daniel
this season and to then actually come
around to really see how they're able to
be human and vulnerable with each other
at the end i hope that people enjoy that
journey this season because i definitely
really enjoyed filming it
you know you called chip right
i know
chip and alex their relationship reaches
an amazing place at the end of this
season it is at once deeply unhealthy i
think but there's a purity to it and a
beauty to it because of how honest they
are with each other
the network wants you on the air tonight
i'm sick
i know that's the point i knew alex was
going to get coveted i just thought whoa
this is going to be interesting to try
to pull this off we did a lot of
research in terms of covid and the
effects of kovid and jen had to really
go there i'm just hoping i get to go
anywhere mimi goes because she's just my
rock this show attracts the most amazing
directors we are so blessed to have mimi
as our captain she's a real visionary
okay alex we are live in three minutes
come on let's do this we were inspired
by chris cuomo sharing the fact that he
kept working he had to show up and do
his show every night or else he was
pretty sure he was gonna die here we go
here we go you ready
either get on the alex levy train
or just stay at the station there's a
beautiful shift in her where you just
see her sort of stop apologizing for who
she is because she's a human being
we leave her at the end of season two i
think
very much like the phoenix rising and i
think we'll be making bold decisions
about being a person instead of a
persona
i'm looking inward and asking myself who
is it that i actually want to be
and then i'm looking in the mirror
and i'm asking if that's actually who i
am for the audience at home hopefully
there's been some clarity around what
matters to you what doesn't and what
should matter and what shouldn't if
we're not trying to draw lessons from
that then we're not alive to the world
we're in
you